savez vous que jean est le seul type sur
terre qui a passé le réveillon avec les
ex de sa femme la femme de jean c'est
sarah la déesse de l'amour et on n'est
que trois à avoir décroché la timbale
voix avec sahara erik a eu deux filles
et xavier a eu mathilde maintenant eric
est marié à pauline et xavier à marie
thomas lui a épousé elisabeth il y a dix
ans mais thomas est sorti avec sarah
bien avant alors que jean a rencontré
sarah il y a un an seulement gens qui
d'ailleurs a été le prof de pauline la
femme d'eric
je ne peux pas avoir d'enfant avec ça je
suis ce terrifiant vaincre
forcément à perth et enfin tébessa c'est
xavier
sa vie c'est du sérum de vérité ça
j'avais couché avec ça j'ai eu un enfant
récemment j'ai pas touché une femme
depuis 1
eric est ce que tu as couché avec sarah
oui ou non par bah oui récemment je veux
dire hors van
damme était là mon coeur
debout les experts
moi je barre de cette baraque
lequel d'entre vous a couché avec sarah
récemment je me dit récemment à
l'altérité
elle adore noël